so
linda's pregnant
yeah that's a special day does it feel
real it does feel
real and special from property brother
to property father drew scott is having
a baby
on tuesday the 43 year old tv
personality announced that his wife
linda fan is pregnant with their first
child drew shared these snaps with linda
and her growing baby bump on instagram
writing in the caption that it quote has
been an adventure to get here the hgtv
star added quote we know we're not alone
in this experience and that everyone's
is filled with unique challenges along
the way before thanking their doctors
family and friends who have offered them
their support
the excited dad to be concluded his post
writing quote it made an overwhelming
time in our lives more manageable we
hope as we grow through this that even
one of you reading this can also feel a
little less lonely in whatever path
you're on
the love birds also shared a video on
youtube documenting their journey to get
pregnant
and they shared a few moments from the
day they learned the news that they were
having a baby
hasn't quite sunk in yet no
i think the thing for me is
we've been planning and we've had really
great support with dr b and molly and
maybe that's why it's not as shocking
but i'm still really really i think it's
shocking because it's been over like
two years i've been actually trying
yeah
of course drew and linda tied the knot
back in 2018 and at the time they sat
down to play a round of the newlywed
game with e.t
who made the first move oh ding ding
ding ding ding what'd you do i had an
amazing pickup line uh linda was we're
at a fashion event and i saw linda
backstage and i she was carrying a
bottle of water i had pizza in hand and
i walked over and i just said where'd
you get that water
very smooth like
and i saw his pizza and i said where'd
you get that pizza love it first pizza
how many children do you guys want
eight
put them
one or two more oh there you go
two to three yeah we've talked about
twins we love kids yeah we she has a big
family and and so so do i like my
extended family and we get lots of fun
time with her nieces and nephews so
makes us want to have kids but are they
going to be cute little lindas are they
going to be sort of tall
lanky awkward drew's who knows well now
they have a baby on the way and drew has
a new show on discovery plus drew's
dream car
why don't we have one of those roller
things what sorry the roller thingy
e.t chatted with drew leading up to the
show's december 18th premiere and he
opened up about building his ultimate
dream car from the ground up with the
help of his twin brother jonathan scott
and celebrity iou joyrides and amstead
and linda explained how she contributed
to her man's new ride in one super sweet
way
tell me about this wonderful emblem yeah
we worked with this artist patty who
makes emblems for cars and it's glassy
enamel and we wanted to incorporate the
scottish heritage and the banff
mountains let me just say
she is underplaying it linda literally
designed it it looks amazing it
incorporates my dad like where he was
born and where he lives i love it
thank you so much it's amazing
[Music]